So listen, there are people who would feel
a sense of satisfaction from what I'm about
to play for you.
I feel no satisfaction whatsoever.
I actually feel despair when I see the video
I'm about to play for you because it's emblematic
of so much of what's wrong with our country.
This is an example of yet again, another Republican
who was very laissez faire, about covid and
stood behind Trump literally and figuratively,
with no mask, defending everything Trump was
doing, praising Trump until he got Coronavirus
himself.
And I'm talking about former New Jersey Republican
Governor Chris Christie, who ended up after
not wearing a mask at the White House at a
super spreader event.
Chris Christie ended up in a hospital, ICU
with covid.
And now Chris Christie is in a national ad
defiantly and powerfully advocating for mask
wearing.
So take a look at the.
And here is Chris Christie specifically with
a message to those refusing to wear a mask.
This message isn't for everyone.
It's for all those people who refuse to wear
a mask, you know, lying in isolation in ICU
for seven days.
I thought about how wrong I was to remove
my mask at the White House today.
I think about how wrong it is to mask wearing,
divide us, especially as we now know you're
twice as likely to get covid-19 if you don't
wear a mask, because if you don't do the right
thing, we could all end up on the wrong side
of history.
Please wear a mask.
So Chris Christie says, as we now know, but
we've known this for months.
So, OK, it's true.
We may be didn't know in February and March
about masks, but Chris Christie got covid
a couple of months ago.
We knew for six months at that point about
the importance of wearing masks and not doing
indoor events, everything that Chris Christie
participated in, which likely got him the
virus.
So I get it.
On the one hand, good for Chris Christie.
And I see lots of leftest retweeting this
ad on Twitter.
OK, but this goes back to one of the real
tragedies of the Republican Party and reactionary
right wing thinking in the United States.
This is not new.
If you've been watching the show, listening
for a while, you've heard me say this before.
His view changed only because he got the virus
and he may only be willing to do this ad because
ultimately Donald Trump already lost and he
knows that there's less of a political risk
to doing it.
This is just like the homophobic Republican
who spends 20 years fighting against gay rights
and then finds out their kid is gay and has
an awakening.
OK, it's great when someone comes around to
the correct position, there is no doubt about
it.
But why does it have to happen only when you
recognize that it affects you personally.
It only happens when you have a kid or what?
Right.
We've talked about the homophobic example.
Can't you simply empathize with the parent
of the gay kid who sees you fighting against
gay rights and have that same awakening?
Couldn't Chris Christie have understood the
importance of mask's without ending up in
the ICU personally after taking his mask off
at the White House?
Why does it take being in an ICU with coronavirus
to understand what we should be doing?
Do you think that there's something physiological
going on where some of us are able to say,
hey, you know what?
I didn't have covered that that I know of.
In fact, maybe I did actually back back in
April.
But that's a different story.
I'm not aware that I certainly had it.
And if I did, I didn't end up in the ICU,
but I still wear a mask and don't do indoor
gatherings and so on and so forth, because
I understand that even if it didn't happen
to me, it's happening to other people.
Why is it that the Republicans seem unable
to do it?
I don't know the answer.
I'm genuinely asking it.
When we see a Republican show, a shred of
humanity and empathy, it's because they or
someone in their family had something happen
to them.
And until that point, they don't seem to care.
Chris Christie is absolutely correct.
And if this video that he did, if this ad
he did convinces someone to wear a mask who
hasn't been all power to Chris Christie, but
this is pathetic that this is what it took
for him to come to this conclusion if he's
pushing deniers to act responsibly.
Thank you, Chris.
Fantastic.
But why did it take until almost a year into
the pandemic if we had had more prominent
Republicans saying these things in March instead
of 15 cases will soon be zero?
It's like a flu.
We're handling it perfectly.
We would be much better off right now.
I prefer public servants.
Who can see beyond how something affects them
personally and understand how things affect
other people and society at large?
So, yeah, I know that there are leftists who
are merely praising Chris Christie, and that's
fine and it's fine to amplify the message.
But this is a microcosm.
This is emblematic of the lack of or inability
to experience empathy that seems to be an
epidemic in and of itself among the American
right.
And I think we can leave it there.
But I'm curious to hear from you.
We'll have more on this as well as the Chris
Christie clip on The David Pakman Show Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.
You can also follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman.
I've gotten so it's funny.
I will do something so random and hear from
500 people and I don't always understand the
logic.
I posted like a 10 second video on my Instagram,
which is David Pakman of me out in a rainstorm
and my umbrella reversing.
And I'm kind of I'm essentially battling the
umbrella and trying to get it under control
like a wild stallion that hasn't yet been
saddled.
And I must have gotten four or five hundred
different messages about this silly little
video.
So anyway, if you want a break from the tragedy
and just want pure comedy, follow me at David
Pakman.
We'll take a quick break.
So much more to talk about today.
Glad you're
with us.